Tommy Hilfiger is coming out with solar
powered jackets yeah that's right we've
got a picture of the solar powered
jackets and why would you wear a solar
power jacket first off I actually think
that looks decently cool um are you guys
I'm barded that part with me so far
before I say why you would wear it the
girl looks like a tardis it's
cool what about the guy lisis give me
some guy fashion I think that is the
ugliest thing I've seen in a long time
yeah I think that they're disgusting if
you made that a little if it was black
if it was just black and you had some of
those solar power things it would be
kind of futuristic took that off and put
a different jacket on it would be great
yeah all right you just don't like that
style jacket like the Plaid hor all
right let's not get hung up on the
fashion too much I'll tell you a little
bit more about what they're doing so
they have jackets obviously for both men
and women and they generate energy on
the go so that you can power your iPhone
and other uh devices they feature
flexible solar panels on the back that
can generate enough power to recharge a
standard smartphone up to four times
they also have two USB ports Kim you're
going to have to give me some ideas on
what we can do with that and 50% of the
proceeds of the jacket are donated to
the fresh air fund who help New York
City kids experience being in the
outdoors how much would you pay for that
jacket $599 retail you know if they
Black Friday this thing we're looking
around $450 I think uh but we're already
passed by Friday so I guess not um I
think this is pretty cool look we're all
carrying around the phones right uh
Starbucks is now going to do this thing
with wireless charging at all their
tables that's supposed to be coming next
year um we're all running out of power
constantly think about our batteries
have drained while we've been sitting
here so this is pretty cool this would
be super useful at a convention like
Comic-Con or something where it's super
sunny and my phone is dying all the time
and I need it for Instagram I need it
wait I'm not sure if you're being
sarcastic is it sunny in Comic-Con isn't
it in a giant of it is outside because
it's all it's taken over San Diego so I
would be able to you know I'll go do
this obstacle course and also charge my
but wearable tech is you know I I like
it I'm a fan but that's very expensive
that's the price point all right so
let's let's not get hung up on the price
point so forgetting the price point and
forgetting the fashion ability of it is
that a word fashion ability sure um are
you down with this idea it's pretty cool
right I me yeah in theory it's great but
I feel like you can't forget the price
and the the fashion of it because you
know wearable tech is definitely the
future but we have to kind of make
strides in terms of what we want to
actually wear and what we can afford to
wear so it's not going to be something
that everyone can can pick up and put on
without feeling silly it's not going to
really matter right so isn't that just
part of just how business goes like even
this for Black Friday I kept seeing
these literally like 40 or 50 inch TVs
that were 200 bucks or 250 bucks I
bought my first plasma whatever it was
like six years ago it was
$2400 so don't we sort of need isn't
that just how business works that we
need some of these expensive things to
start it and then eventually the cheap
guys it's always going to be more
expensive and bulkier at first that's
why I'm usually not an early adopter uh
so yeah wait a few years and maybe it'll
be 100 bucks so if you power your phone
with this thing what are you doing with
the those two other USB ports charging
your iPad so you got your iPad your
phone you could I don't think I want to
walk around with every device attach to
my jacket that's starting to see by the
way this was making me think you know we
did so many stories probably about a
year ago about Google Glass and everyone
was going to be wearing it I've
literally here in La which is a pretty
early adopter place right I've literally
only seen one guy wearing Google Glass
and he's this guy in West Hollywood who
wears Google Glass all the time and he
also rides a uh what are that scooter
thing Segway and he rides a Segway
because it looks ridiculous because
those things rid I mean they they they
it could have been I mean if if Google
Glass looked like something people would
actually wear I feel like it would have
gone a lot farther and if it were more
affordable yeah do you think there's
some uh hesitancy to go this route of
wearing all this stuff like we're so
inundated with technology all the time
that I do think part of us it's like
well it's also I mean wearable tech has
it's cool I think it's useful but it
hasn't really caught on as much as it
should have or projected to have uh by
now a lot of it is is maybe it's fashion
related I mean things take a while to
catch on you feel weird being feeling
like I'm the only one who looks like
this it's it's uh it's going to take a
while to Cotton On I think now Louis if
they took that lovely sweater you're
wearing right now and put some solar
panels on it sure yeah I'm not against
that you're not against that but here's
the problem why would I be wearing the
sweater if it were really sunny outside
you could still get some r that's a good
point these things are jackets and you I
assume you get less so I don't know this
for a fact but I would imagine if you're
we somewhere that you need a jacket that
the sun is probably less strong for the
solar panels you would get something
you'd get something You' get a little
juice and you don't need a ton of power
to power the iPhone okay that's my
completely unscientific I just mean like
what about like a like a like a hat with
solar panels on it oh that's more like
didn't I think I feel like uh Michael J
fox wore that maybe in Back to the
Future too he might have possibly I'm
sort of maybe EMP power the hoverboard
yeah that exactly that's how hoverboards
will be powered in the
future